[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas commencé au début nom prénom date et
lieu de naissance de jésus je suis née
il ya un peu plus de 2000 ans mais vous
voulez dire tâche jésus est le paradis
n'est ou dans tout ça c'est voulu
transformer paradis en enfer bien voilà
mon cher c'est moi je suis là pour te
pourrir la vie est comme ça un jour tu
l'apprécient
et vous voulez quoi au juste notre
famille unie va bientôt nous quitter
j'aimerais offrir sa dernière histoire
d'amour d'affaires du golfe ont
clairement comme ça [ __ ] c'est une
mauvaise imitation de denis robert de
niro de niro sessad aignan qui tu parles
pas de mort tu parles pas de vie si à la
vie à la mort du tout les bizuths afin
et invite fit speedy
et à votre père
je te lui valut viens moi-même
vous êtes venus seuls sur ce bateau oui
pourquoi abbas en général quand on vient
seul sait que c'est qu'il ya un problème
va donc vous aussi vous avez un problème
et alors vous êtes vie je vais aller me
consoler avec le premier venu cette fois
ci le premier venu n'est pas le dernier
décompte pourquoi pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on pensait que l'amour ces mecs-là vie
maintenant oui